welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and a crazy new scene from the batman
just hit the internet and by crazy i do
mean crazy y'all as barry cogan's joker
chuckles his way through an intense
anniversary reunion with his old pal
robert battenson in his debut in matt
reeves critically acclaimed a new
detective comic of a dc film so let's go
ahead and analyze just what we all just
witnessed and what this might mean for
the future of this new batman universe
particularly with this new arkham asylum
tv show coming to hbo max in the near
future so let's dive into it my nerd
babies and of course huge spoilers for
the batman coming up so please do not
watch this video if you have not yet
seen several politicians being murdered
with a home depot product and hey go to
omaze.com new rockstars and enter for
your chance to win a tesla model x and
support a great cause now this scene
obviously takes place inside the walls
of arkham state hospital as we can see
the words plastered on the back of the
clown prince of crime at the beginning
of the clip as this arkham security
guard leaves the visitation room so
these two lovebirds could get
reacquainted but what's interesting here
is that despite being more commonly
known as arc of asylum in the comics the
institution wasn't named arkham state
hospital until 2019's joker film and has
been unique to that joker universe and
though the batman has been confirmed to
be in a separate universe than the joker
film i still thought it was a nice touch
considering that the last time we saw
the joker on the big screen he was
locked away in an arkham state hospital
as well so it's a nice little bridging
between these two variant jokers inside
of these variant arkham state hospitals
but anyways after the batman hands over
the riddler's file with a silent look of
disdain on his face joker jokingly calls
it a present for their anniversary that
is apparently coming up very soon
this very much implies that the focus of
this new batman's first year of batman
was barry cogan's joker himself which
makes sense considering how we see bruce
keeping an extremely meticulous log of
all of his bats capades in a bat log
called notes and observations gotham
project year 2 during the events of the
batman with year 2 naturally implying
that bruce is currently in his second
year during these events and this would
also explain why the streets of gotham
already have grown to fear the dark
knight by the start of the batman and
possibly why the batman film starts off
with bruce beating up a bunch of
pale-faced thugs because there's a good
chance that these guys could have been
the leftovers of the joker's original
clown gang with this shot of batman
shocking one of these goons as they
grimace with teeth showing being a
clever allusion to how the joker likes
to electrocute people with his prank and
shake zappers in other batman media like
i really dig how matt reeves started off
this new batman universe with an
infamous dark and a dangerous figure
with a mysterious tragic past much like
you know george lucas did with darth
vader in a new boat with batman's
entrance inspiring as much dread as the
sith lord himself not a bad blueprint to
follow and the history between this
batman and the joker is front and center
in this scene as batman tells the joker
that the reason why he was there was to
get the perspective of a serial killer
kind of like in a silence of the lamb's
type of way and this makes sense
considering that at this point in
batman's career the joker is likely the
sickest serial killer that he knows and
one that he knew would be more than
happy to analyze the art of a fellow man
of murder like the riddler was turning
out to be after the murders of a senator
and a police commissioner with joker
even complimenting the batman on usually
being ahead of the curve when it comes
to catching disaster masterminds like
him
any theories
yeah really
you're normally so happy
what i really love about this whole
interaction is that it adds a whole
layer of meaning to jim gordon's
exasperated this guy is hilarious at the
site of riddler's thumb drive in the
film because jim appears to have already
had his fill of hilarious criminals in
year 1 with the joker so he's like this
guy's hilarious
here we go again and thanks to omaze for
sponsoring this video omaze is a
fundraising platform that gives you the
chance to win once in a lifetime
experiences and awesome prizes while
raising monies for non-profit
organizations you could win a brand new
tesla model x plan this bad boy is
all-electric has over a thousand
horsepower and has a 313 mile range on
just one charge the stylish suv has a
six month wait to get one from a
dealership but you can enter for a
chance to win on omaze and you'll be
helping support two different charities
give power is a charity on a mission to
help the 2.2 billion people around the
world who don't have access to safely
managed drinking water 501c3 is a new
type of non-profit for a younger
generation focused on energy food water
and shelter other campaigns on omaze let
you enter for a chance to win a lake
house or a tricked out bmw and support
causes like special olympics usa and the
thurgood marshall college fund for your
chance to win a tesla model x plaid and
support two great causes go to omaze.com
new rockstars today and thanks again to
omaze for sponsoring this video and hey
speaking of bloody fingers with the
joker directly mentioning the murders of
the senator and police commissioner
while his nasty ass bloody fingers
peruse over the drive clue that the
riddler left for bruce and alfred to
solve at the beginning of the film i'm
willing to bet that this deleted scene
was meant to take place right after
batman and gordon tried to understand
the riddler's motives over the very
corpse of a savagely murdered corrupted
commissioner savage but it seems that
matt reeves opted to take the scene out
in order for us to see the bat and the
cat spy on the soon to be slain district
attorney at penguin's place and you know
if we're gonna talk about these bloody
fingers we gotta talk about this new
joker's look because my god do i want to
see how this man got those scars because
look at the front and back of his head
like his whole body seems severely
disfigured through the means of a
chemical burn which is very fitting
considering how many of joker's many
comic book origins have him starting off
as a relatively low criminal before
falling into a vat of toxic waste at ace
chemicals but instead of emerging from
the vat as attractive as your you know
margot robbie's or a jared leto director
matt reeves opted for a more realistic
take on a chemical burn victim that
would match up with his more realistic
take on his gotham as a whole like we
are definitely seeing a joker without
his wig or clown makeup for sure here
that's okay joker's boyfriend would
never judge him without makeup they love
each other too much and the joker's
bloody fingers in this clip very much
suggest a very recent pattern of
self-mutilation that the joker has
seemingly picked up during his time at
arkham possibly going insane without any
like-minded psychopaths like the batman
to chat with that is until the riddler's
file appears to spark a little hope
within the joker because maybe if he
helps his best friend batman catch this
riddler guy then maybe batman could
return the favor by bringing this
intriguing new friend to the joker at
arkham to start a batman fan club
because as we can see from this clip the
joker claims to know who the riddler is
and correctly guesses that edward
nashton was a nobody with a grudge
looking to be a somebody vindicated by
bloody vengeance by imitating the
batman's work as gotham's masked avenger
and with the joker himself historically
having used batman's very existence as
inspiration to commit more crimes i can
see this joker very much seeing a
kindred spirit within gotham's carpet
tucker killer but now that we know that
this is the case through this deleted
scene and we saw how the joker
manipulated a distraught riddler at the
end of the batman i would really love if
matt reeves new arkham asylum show on
hbo max focused on one iconic batman
villain per episode laying out their
origin stories and how they ultimately
end up meeting the joker and the riddler
at arkham state hospital at the end
almost like a black mirror ask anthology
where each episode serves as its own
separate story leading up to this huge
finale where all the villains all meet
up to break out of gotham together
holding hands screaming free at last
free at last fake gorilla grodd almighty
we are free at last don't do that
because the ghost of martin luther king
will come and haunt you forever
and just how could joker escape well
let's just say batman left that visiting
room with one last paper clip that he
came in with
i see you joker sneaky sneaky naughty
naughty but anyways that is my analysis
for this super exciting first look of
the joker in the batman what did you
guys think of the deleted scene let us
know in the comments section below
because i want to know what you guys
think of the joker and remember go to
omaze.com new rockstars to enter for
your chance to win a tesla model x and
support a really great cause and thanks
again to omaze for sponsoring this video
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and do
not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to get our new batman
inspired shirts thanks again for
watching i love you guys so so much and
i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you